foreign
let's go to the City of Angels and talk
to Selena hola Selena how are we doing
hi I'm doing good how are you so good
things going okay
you know what I mean so it's a roller
coaster but
well yeah that's all yes I agree so
what's up how can I help
okay
um so so unfortunately
um on April 24th I went to the ER
um just to find out I have an ectopic
pregnancy oh gosh I'm sorry
traumatic
and
what made it worse for me really was
well first off I didn't have the surgery
I don't know if you know too much about
that I do my in fact my wife had ectopic
pregnancy that ruptured and it was a it
was very very near miss so yeah no I've
been down that road
um yeah so um thankfully I my tube
wasn't ruptured so I was able to get the
shot
um and that was super painful in itself
can we stop right there yeah
can you take a huge deep breath for me
and hold it
hold it for one
two
three exhale
how far how far along were you
um so I was only only three weeks
you're not allowed to say the word only
on the show when it comes to pregnancy
okay
can I ask you a deeply personal question
yeah what name did you have in your mind
um well I have a few names but if it's a
boy it's going to be Alexander after his
dad and then if it was a girl Arabella
well
what was he or she because you know
I I didn't know because you didn't it
yeah okay so but all of our kids have a
names so it had to be with an a
awesome awesome
um so for whatever it's worth
and um
I've had the honor and the Heartbreak of
sitting with countless women who've sat
with in just dealing with pregnancy loss
um I picked one
and I've got the names of all of the
miscarriages my wife and I have been
through she obviously she carries a line
share of it I've got a tattooed on my
body
having some sort of marker or moment for
the loss is really important okay
and I I don't think that's what the call
is about but I just want to put that out
there for you when people start using
words like only and this and
I want you just to take a second and
and and put a put a marker on the ground
okay
yeah
and I think that's why I'm calling it
because I feel like um
everyone in my life has been kind of
dismissive about this
so
um my mom she's not very like loving
so she was very like okay well it
happened let's get over it and then my
husband
he just constantly is working so he was
like yes it sucks but let's move on with
our lives and I'm the kind of person who
I'm like okay well I just want to wallow
in this for a minute
yeah so you get to wallow and your mom
was was not loving before this right
correct yeah yeah she was a pageant Mom
oh man so you're a pageant gal huh
uh yeah so it was pageant then it turned
into Girl Scouts and then when I went
through my goth phase it was just
I love a good goth phase man
um
oh man what a mess okay so what's your
question how can I help
um
suction really is how is how do I
but how do I mainly for my husband
explain to him that this wasn't just a
medical mishap that happened with me
this is something that I'm mourning like
a loss of a child how is he responding
is he pretending this didn't happen is
he being an idiot like like
is he saying dumb like tell me what's
going on with him
well first off he's a tanker driver who
works night shift so he needs to sleep
during the day and I that's very
important because it's dangerous but his
way of coping with things is I'm just
going to work and
um provide for my family and yes it
sucks but it happens let's move on those
are his exact words
you
yeah
so I mean he's perfect in every way
except for he's very like he is not for
the grind yes that's Celine that's the
dumbest thing you've said in this whole
call I
uh he's not perfect in every way
um
so I'm heartbroken for a couple of
reasons one because I said something
very similar
he's a he's a tanker driver I was a nerd
so I didn't say not a big deal but I did
try to explain it away as though it
wasn't a big deal
and there's no excuse other than to say
I didn't know
I didn't understand I didn't know the
depths
and very similar like your husband I
knew one thing
when there was chaos and I knew my wife
was hurting but I didn't understand why
I didn't understand how
I did know I could help out around the
house by making more money so I just
went to work
and in a really backward strange way
um
sounds like he's trying to tell you he
loves you
yeah
I know that I know
I know I will just like be so upset and
let it fester and to the point where it
explodes yeah and he can read that from
a mile away he knows the minute I'm
upset and he tries to talk it out and
yeah I know it's just I need to work on
that well it's less that and it's more
after our second miscarriage when my
wife said the words I'm tired of my body
killing babies
that's when I finally got the extent of
her pain
I didn't understand
and it's not an excuse other than to say
I didn't know and I didn't even know to
ask
and yet that level of clarity and
insight
while hard for me to hear gave me a
whole new entryway so if I could do it
all over again I would have talked
infinitely less
I would have listened more and I would
have asked questions that invited that
level of honesty
and also
I've forgiven myself and I've committed
to doing better and I've moved on
so I tell you to tell to tell to do this
I wouldn't say it's a thing to work on
but you've never experienced this before
Fair
this is our first time and you had a mom
that trained you to take your feelings
and wad them up in a ball and flush them
on a toilet so that you could be a
porcelain human making your way through
the world right
yes you were a display item for her so
you don't have a model of what's sitting
in grief looks like and that's okay
grief will drag you underwater whether
you whether you have a model for it or
not right
and so
there's something profound and Powerful
about telling your husband hey we need
to have a hard conversation
and maybe you write it down
but give giving him the truth about how
you feel
and how hard this loss is and being very
specific about how hard it is
how specific
I didn't understand that women when they
experienced miscarriage they feel
betrayed by their own bodies
and they even the most powerful High
performing business women
have questions about self-worth I didn't
know any of that stuff
I worked I worked in Toronto right and I
didn't know
I didn't know that it can be so annoying
that you begin to question everything
about everything I didn't know
I didn't know about names
right so all that to say is
invite him into that conversation
now can I ask you a hard question
yeah
what is it about him that makes it you
not feel safe to have that conversation
because you've avoided it for some
reason I can tell you I was not a safe
place for my wife I wasn't
yeah why isn't he safe
um well first off we've been
we've been married it's going to be our
fifth year being married but we've been
together going on 10 years
so
um in our early years we were ravers and
you were what ravers
yeah so we used to go out partying every
weekend
yes and
um we just doing bad decisions and oh my
gosh Alina just say it what are you
you're like like him and him huh
I know oh yeah so I there's just been
situations where I feel like I'm on
walking on eggshells with him because I
feel like the rug's gonna get pulled out
for me at any minute so there's been
times where
um either he's being a little too
flirtatious with girls not so much
anymore but
um either that or we when we were
younger I did let him have a threesome
twice so
you let him have one or you participated
with him you said that funny
sure okay so what does that have to do
with right now
I always feel this insecurity that I
can't just
be open
because I feel like the reg is going to
get pulled out for me what does that
mean what does a rug get pulled out mean
[Applause]
he's going to either leave
or
um
something's gonna happen where we end up
divorced
why do you think that's happening
I
I had 30 younger years when we were
younger and
just the way that when alcohol gets in
the way of feelings and then there was
yelling matches
and then the
whole him asking to be with other women
it's just made it made me very jaded
of course that would make anybody jaded
yes
but you picked up the phone and called
me recently why
to talk with my husband it's
I want to be open with him all the time
but I find it very hard because I feel
like if I say one thing wrong
that
um
it could result in a ending and I don't
know has he said that Selena
no he has not so are you imagining this
I think so
let me just tell you this
Secrets will kill you
and so if you hedge a relationship and
you hold the stuff that is important to
you like grief and loss and
I don't want to have sex with you and
another woman
if you need other women fine I'm out of
this relationship
but the more you cash in
your own
being your own soul your own
authenticity
as some sort of hedge against him
leaving he is married to somebody he
knows he feels it in his bones
that is not being full with fully honest
with him
which is the best driver to send
somebody out
yeah and he's going to use you as the
excuse even though there's not one
you see how this just creates a
self-perpetuating cycle
yeah
when's the last time he mentioned
wanting to be with somebody else
um his birthday so
um at the beginning of this month
two weeks after your miscarriage
yeah
Selena lead with that good God
yeah and I think because I wasn't vocal
to him about no no it's because he's an
ah I'm trying not to swear with all my
guts
yeah that level of insensitivity is
disgusting
it's embarrassing
yeah
um stop just sit in that for a second
yeah he doesn't deserve to be with you
Selena
people do goofy things when they're 22.
people do unhealthy things in their 22.
people will do all whatever
you're gonna have to open hand some of
those choices y'all made when you're
going to Raves and stuff get to let that
stuff just be a part of your past we all
have them
but you're also gonna have to sit in the
fact that after
a really traumatic experience that you
didn't even have the words to discuss
his response was you know it's birthday
time
yeah
yeah exactly
exactly your pain and your hurt are
Justified okay
I'm disgusted with you
okay
do you need to take a break
from him
from him no
and I know he's not thinking of what I'm
feeling in the moment that's the problem
yeah
he's your husband
the vast majority of his thoughts in his
day should be focused on what his wife
is thinking and feeling
with the hope that the vast majority of
your thoughts are about how you can help
meet his needs what he's thinking what
he's experiencing
yeah
yeah and that is me as a human and very
much the caregiver of everyone
so
here's what I want you to be thinking
about here's what I want you to do okay
you've been protecting him for so long
you and I can't unwind this in a phone
call
what I can tell you is you need to talk
to somebody very very quickly okay
because you've got a you need to sit
down with a professional counselor
a to talk about how to grieve
because you're gonna have to grieve the
distance between you and your mom that
should not have been there but was
you're gonna have to grieve the fact
that your mom used you as a as a
figurine for her own
ah
um
her own
self
she propped herself up using you
yes
and
and now in the moments when you need
your husband the most he's like hey
very similarly
I want to use you too for my birthday
and all that's a lot and only the only
response you've got in your soul
is to look in the mirror and blame
yourself and try to fix it
and you didn't do anything wrong with
your mom
that was on her
and I'll tell you this even the most
sexually adventurous people I know
would never
in a million years
13 or 14 days removed from such tragedy
be like hey you know what
it's Madness
yeah
so I want you to will you commit to
talking to somebody
I will I'll look into finding account
s yeah that's different than actually
making the call you promise you'll make
a call I'll make a call today do you
promise you'll go to the appointment
yes I promise you just promise in front
of all of America actually we only have
like 18 listeners but you just promised
in front of all of them
I'll do it I I meant yeah
you are worth so much more
than being the relational janitor for
everybody in your life cleaning up
everybody else's messes
okay I agree yeah
I'm sorry sweetheart
no no butts it's just a lot
yeah
no butts just and it's a lot and it
hurts right now and I'm sorry
he you has helped me out um I'm a big
Harry Potter person and you're like a
Dumbledore to my Harry Potter is that an
old joke
is that an old joke no a pretty old I
understand no oh you're not too far off
from me I'll take Dumbledore all day
long so I'm I'm grateful
um
you
are worth so much more you're worth
being well
please call somebody today this is going
to take some time to unravel this
because it's it's wired into you
and let's say this
um I don't know him I haven't talked to
him
I'd be happy to talk to your husband if
you want to call if he wants to call in
and maybe he's just hurting too and he
doesn't know how to do it and he just
said stupid things and put stupid things
on the table to try to make himself feel
better so I don't beat him up
too bad
it's frustrating as that is uh maybe
he's hurting too
all I have to say is you can't you can't
do anything about his nonsense other
than to say no and
go be the champion of your healing
let me know how it goes I'll walk with
you every step of the way Selena